hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an American Horror Thriller
film called Old spoilers ahead watch out
ants take care
[Music]
it's time to get shyamalamund at the
start of the movie The Kappa family gets
invited to a resort for a holiday trip
the parents guy and Prisa have never
heard of the resort before but
nonetheless they are excited once they
reach it the entire staff greets them
including the manager himself a woman
that arrives and gives them welcome
drinks after a while she leads the kids
Trent and Maddox outside while several
other people are chilling at the candy
station the kids meet idlib the
manager's nephew Trent immediately
befriends him and the two start
exploring the place meanwhile Maddox and
her parents get into their bathing suits
and have a fun time on the beach at
first glance it appears as if the family
is about to have the time of their lives
however little do they know that they
are in for one hell of a horror ride
probably a twist ending too the next
morning we are introduced to the other
families over breakfast Charles A
renowned surgeon has come along with his
mother Agnes his wife Crystal and their
six-year-old daughter Kara Crystal hits
on the waiter right in front of her
husband I hope I get super rich someday
so I can have a broken relationship too
then there is the Carmichael couple
consisting of Jaron and Patricia the
latter is suffering from epilepsy which
often causes her to have seizures even
today at breakfast she experiences a
violent seizure but luckily the surgeon
Charles helps her up meanwhile the
resort manager approaches the Kappa
family and tells them about a beautiful
beach that lies just five kilometers
from there he also mentions that he has
already arranged a vehicle and other
Essentials for their trip Gaia and Prisa
are perplexed as to why they are being
treated like royalty nonetheless they
agree shortly after the family boards
the bus and gets ready for their trip to
their dismay Chris and his family also
join in making the trip not so exclusive
after a while they drive past a gate
that clearly says off limits none of the
guests notice it as they are too caught
up in their own activities once they
reach the end of the road the driver
drops them off and points them in the
direction of the beach he doesn't even
bother to escort them there or carry
their belongings before leaving he
mentions that he'll pick them up at 5 PM
in the next scene the group continues
walking through the forest and into a
narrow Cavern from there they eventually
arrive at the beach it is an absolutely
stunning place just like the resort
manager had promised wasting no time
both the families start unpacking their
stuff until they notice a lonely looking
man sitting nearby he is revealed to be
a famous rapper named mid-sized sedan
mid-sized sedan Maddox immediately
recognizes him and tries to get his
autograph but her dad tells her to leave
the guy alone after a while the three
kids get to playing and find numerous
items buried in the sand most of them
are toys while some are other objects
that one would normally bring to the
beach it gets even weirder here the
beach doesn't contain a single fish not
even small mollusks and you know what
they say no mollusks get the get the
hell out of there meanwhile Trent being
a curious kid goes swimming alone he
splashes against the small waves and is
having a fun time until a dead body
comes floating towards him terrified he
screams for help and the adults
immediately come to rescue him the dead
body is brought to the shore and the
surgeon Charles deduces that she had
drowned just recently he then asserts
that mid-sized sedan killer as there was
no one else on the beach when they
arrived dude must a midsize murdered her
ass the accusation becomes even more
compelling when sedan is seen bleeding
from the nose indicating that he had a
fight with the woman the latter tries to
explain Lane that he had nothing to do
with the incident but no one believes
him meanwhile the little boy Trent keeps
complaining that his swimsuit feels
tighter could have something to do with
that dead naked body on the beach this
could be the start of a problem for
little Trent Charles's mother Agnes also
says that she is having difficulties in
breathing sensing that something bad is
happening Charles tries calling for help
but there is no signal in the area just
then the couple from earlier the
Carmichaels arrives there they have also
been dropped off by the driver on the
resort manager's orders the terrified
group immediately briefs them on the
situation and hence the husband Jaron
decides to stop the driver from leaving
however as soon as he runs inside the
cavern he falls unconscious a few
seconds later he wakes up on the beach
with a bad headache everyone is confused
by what just happened but before they
can investigate it they learned that
Agnes has stopped breathing the group
immediately rushes to her and Charles
tries his best to resuscitate his mother
unfortunately all of his efforts go in
vain meanwhile the Carmichaels are
talking to the Kappa kids to distract
them Jaren the boy his age to which
Trent replies 6. the Carmichaels find it
hard to believe as he looks considerably
older just then Prisa arrives at the
scene and is stunned to see her children
miraculously they have aged by a few
years making them impossible to
recognize seeing the chaos unfolding
around him sedan makes a run for it and
Charles chases after him however as soon
as they reach the Caravan they black out
and regain Consciousness back on the
beach witnessing all of this a worried
Prisa asserts that they should find
another way out of the place
unfortunately every time one of them
gets near the large Canyon they lose
Consciousness and end up on the beach
again this means that they are trapped
for good with two dead bodies around
them to make matters worse the children
are aging so rapidly that it will be
difficult to find new clothes for them
we're gonna have to see our kids naked
Panic sets in and the adults start
brainstorming on what to do next the cap
is believed that a virus is causing all
the anomalies while Charles who has
started becoming paranoid makes a cut on
sedan's face with a knife someone's got
to call Charles out on his racism
surprisingly the cut gets healed
instantly almost as if it never existed
after a while Maddox takes sedan away
and asks him the truth about the place
the latter promises that he's as
clueless as they are as the two get
comfortable talking sedan reveals that
he suffers from a rare condition which
stops his blood from clotting meanwhile
the adults also discover that the girl
they found dead on the beach was
suffering from sclerosis just then
Priestess starts losing her senses and
soon falls to the ground it turns out
she is suffering from a tumor and this
is the main reason why her marriage with
guy was falling apart before they
arrived on the beach it was a tiny tumor
but now it has grown to become the size
of a tennis ball with time running out
Charles decides to perform a surgery
with the knife he has however as soon as
he makes an incision it heals instantly
just like it did with sedan to make
matters worse Charles starts talking to
himself before arriving at the beach he
had displayed symptoms of schizophrenia
but now the disease is taking over him
nice try Charles we know you're just
racist fortunately the rest of the group
helps him snap out of it so that he can
continue with the operation Charles then
makes another cut near priest's abdomen
and this time everyone holds the opening
so that it doesn't heal they only
release it after Charles takes out the
giant tumor and as soon as the wound
heals Prisa regains Consciousness she is
no longer sick now unfortunately their
happy moment doesn't last long as they
realize that the dead woman from earlier
has now turned into dust and Bones her
body has been taken out only a few hours
ago but somehow it has completely
decomposed Prisa who is a museum curator
examines the bones and explains that
something like this takes at least seven
years to decompose this is when the
group finally realizes that time is
moving faster on this beach Prisa
calculates it precisely and concludes
that half an hour here is equivalent to
a full year in human life elsewhere the
kids Trent and Kara are seen munching on
the remaining food when they return
everyone is shocked to see them all
grown up not only that Kara is heavily
pregnant with a child they must have had
sex like seven seconds ago realizing
that she may give birth any time now
Charles and the others lay her down and
prepare to get the baby out Crystal also
wants to be with her daughter but she
passes out due to anxiety when she wakes
up she finds that the Kara has given
birth to a baby but it is now dead time
moved so fast for the baby that it
didn't even get a chance to consume food
and build its muscles Trent looks at all
this and becomes confused as despite
being a grown-up he still thinks like a
six-year-old on the other hand Charles
has started to lose it in one instance
he threatens jiren to go away while in
another he tells his wife to put on
makeup saying she looks ugly Charles
eventually crosses the limit when he
grabs sedan and repeatedly stabs him
with a knife the poor rapper doesn't
even get a chance to heal due to his
condition which prevents blood from
clotting devastated yearn decides to
cross the waves and call for help saying
risking his life is better than dying
here slowly after he leaves guy slowly
takes the knife away from Charles who at
this point is become totally paranoid
seeing this he suddenly realizes
something all the families that arrived
at the beach had something in common at
least one of their members was suffering
from an ailment for instance Prisa had a
tumor Charles was suffering from racism
sedan had a rare blood condition and the
dead woman was suffering from multiple
sclerosis guy then asks his wife where
she got the invitation card Prisa
reveals that she got it on a random
sweepstakes which was on the back of her
Pharmacy receipt this concludes that the
resort owners already knew their medical
histories in the next scene when Maddox
goes for a swim she comes across a dead
body it is revealed to be that of yearn
thank God I couldn't pronounce that
guy's name he must have blacked out
inside the water and drowned similar to
what happened to the woman from earlier
seeing him Patricia cries in agony while
the remaining group becomes even more
devastated as they have literally
nowhere to escape however Cara does not
want to give up so easily she decides to
climb up the canyon and almost succeeds
in it unfortunately just as she reached
the top she blacks out and Falls to her
death seconds later Patricia starts
convulsing violently and she passes away
too in this way two more corpses are
added to the collection soon the day
turns into night and the Kappa couple
slowly starts losing their senses at
this point they can't even Recall why
they are trying to leave this beautiful
place on the other hand their children
have Unearthed a book which apparently
belonged to the people that came before
them in it the names of all the people
are mentioned along with their addresses
and ailments just then Trent's attention
is diverted by a light coming from the
top of a hill on a closer look he finds
out that it is a camera this means that
someone is inspecting them closely
meanwhile Charles who has become a
ticking Time Bomb slowly approaches guy
to finish him off the latter cannot see
it because he has become nearly blind
soon Charles lunges at him and starts
slashing his body with a knife preset is
just nearby but she cannot hear it as
she has become deaf however when she
eventually finds out what's going on she
grabs a rusty knife and attacks Charles
with it she manages to make a small cut
on his arms but this is enough to kill
him as the rust immediately enters his
veins elsewhere the siblings slowly
enter the cave where they run into an
aging Crystal she doesn't want anyone to
see her hideous face so she tries
killing the children with rocks however
when she tries picking up a big one her
bones break it immediately heals but in
the wrong direction deforming her
Crystal dies a painful death shortly
after after the commotion ends it is
only the Kappa family that is standing
they regroup near the beach for one last
time and Guy emotionally says that he
loves his family a lot saying this he
passes away Prisa also succumbs to her
old age soon the children are distraught
as without their parents they are
helpless the next morning they wake up
in their late 40s knowing that they will
also end up like their parents Trent and
Maddox decide to spend the remainder of
their time playing they start making
sand castles and this is when Trent
remembers that the resort manager's
nephew idlib had given him a puzzle to
solve since they have a lot of of time
Trent brings out the puzzle and
eventually deciphers it it reads my
uncle doesn't like the coral with this
message the siblings realize that the
coral has all the answers to their
questions hence without wasting any time
they dive into the water and head to the
coral soon they come across an
underwater tunnel and as they try to get
through it maddox's dress gets stuck on
a piece of coral the scene then cuts to
a man observing the beach from the hills
he is none other than M Night Shyamalan
himself his twists are getting so
powerful that he's injecting himself
into his own films what will he do next
what will he do next what will he do but
actually he is none other than the
driver who dropped the families off
there after confirming that everyone is
dead he calls his boss and briefs him on
the situation then he packs his
belongings and leaves following this we
are taken to a lab where several
prominent scientists are researching
different medicines the resort manager
is also there and he tells everyone that
trial 73 is over her he also reminds
them that because of this beach they
have been able to save millions of lives
using their medicine you would think
after 73 trials he wouldn't have to give
this speech anymore here we get to know
that the resort is actually a sham for a
medicine company they use the beach to
conduct clinical trials on people so
that they can get the results in a
matter of minutes as opposed to years
the welcome drinks that they provide to
the guests are actually mixed with trial
medicines for their particular illnesses
elsewhere we see the Kappa siblings who
have somehow managed to survive the
deadly waves they are now back in the
resort with the notebook they found on
the beach soon they find a police
officer who is also on holiday and tell
them everything that happened to make
him understand the siblings even hand
him the notebook which has the list of
all the missing people the cop makes
some calls and concludes that the people
are actually missing the fact that there
is a capable policeman in this movie is
the real twist in the final scene the
medical lab is busted and all the
scientists are taken into custody as for
the Kappa siblings they are escorted
home in a chopper subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching